In 1980 America, the Cold War was still very
much hot, Ronald Reagan was elected President,
and the United States’ Olympic hockey team
shockingly upset the USSR in what would be
dubbed “The Miracle on Ice.”
Oh, and the new president of Iraq, Saddam
Hussein, was given a key to the city of Detroit.
How did this come to pass?
Honoring an individual with a key to the city
is actually a more tangible variation of another
practice known as “Freedom of the City”
or, if conferred onto the military, “Freedom
of Entry.”
More commonly called this in Europe, the practice
traces back to ancient Rome and their honoring
of the sacred boundary known as the “pomerium.”
The pomerium, Latin meaning “behind the
wall,” was the open space just inside of
the old city’s’ walls.
This space was dedicated to the gods as gratitude
for protection.
Besides the religious significance, the authority
of a Roman general was only valid outside
the pomerium and not within the city’s walls.
No military affairs were allowed beyond the
pomerium.
In fact, any soldier or general who crossed
that line lost all military power and became
simple civilians.
The only exception was during victory celebrations,
in which generals and soldiers entered the
city in honor to celebrate their success in
battle.
In other words, they had the “Freedom of
the City.”
It was in medieval Europe when physical keys
started being used, around the sixth or seventh
century.
When a monarch or ruler came upon a city or
town, the leaders would greet him and hold
a celebration in his honor (with dancing,
food, wine…lots of wine).
They would, then, present him with a real
key to the city’s gate, allowing this ruler
unlimited access.
There was also a related custom of giving
such keys to certain respected merchants and
tradesmen, who could enter the city without
needing to pay a tax or toll.
It seems the first time such an honor was
given in the United States was in New York
City on June 27, 1702.
Mayor Philip French (mayor of New York City
for only one year) gave the Viscount Cornbury,
Edward Hyde, the British governor of New York
and considered the most powerful man in the
colonies, “Freedom of the City.”
Additionally, Mayor French declared that all
those in the city who were too poor to purchase
their own freedoms were given “Freedom of
the City Gratis” for the day.
So that’s how the custom of giving a key
to the city started and how it made its way
to the United States.
So why was Saddam Hussein given such an honor
by the city of Detroit?
Hussein became President of Iraq on July 16,
1979.
Six days later, he ordered the execution of
twenty one Iraqi government officials (including
five ministers) who were accused of being
“traitors.”
Hussein was a Sunni Muslim, though religion
was never truly a huge part of his belief
system.
What Hussein did value was loyalty and political
support.
So, when Reverend Jacob Yasso of the Chaldean
Sacred Heart in Detroit, Michigan publicly
congratulated Hussein on his rise to power,
the compliment didn’t go unnoticed.
Jacob Yasso was born in Telkaif, Iraq and
after high school, was recruited to Rome where
he completed his masters degree in Philosophy
and Theology.
In 1960, he was ordained a priest in the Chaldean
Catholic Church.
Chaldean Catholics are Catholics whose ethnicity
stems from the ancient area of Mesopotamia,
more specifically northern Iraq, southeast
Turkey, Syria, and northwest Iran.
In 1964, he was appointed to serve the growing
Chaldean community in Detroit.
In response to Yasso’s congratulations,
Saddam sent the church $250,000.
This came as a surprise to Yasso considering
this regime had actually criticized Yasso
for questioning their nationalization of Iraqi
schools.
According to an interview Yasso gave in 2003
with the AP, Saddam Hussein was making donations
to Chaldean churches across the world at that
time, so giving money to his church wasn’t
necessarily out of the ordinary for Iraq’s
president.
Plus, Detroit had the largest Chaldean population
in the United States, who predominately supported
the rise of Hussein in Iraq.
Yasso and Hussein kept in touch, and about
a year later, in 1980, along with about twenty
five people from the Detroit Chaldean community,
he was a guest of the Iraqi government and
arrived in Baghdad.
Then, he was led into Saddam’s palace.
In the same interview, Yasso states “We
were received on the red carpet.”
At some point during the celebration, Yasso
presented Saddam Hussein a gift from then-mayor
of Detroit, Coleman Young, a key to the city,
which of course at this point in the practice
of giving keys out didn’t unlock anything,
but was merely a symbolic honor.
This act of honoring of a man today generally
thought of as having been a ruthless tyrant,
didn’t happen in a vacuum.
In the late 70s, the United States employed
the well-known philosophy, “an enemy of
our enemy is our friend.”
Saddam Hussein’s Iraq was engaged in a war
against Iran.
Considering the US’s own issues with Iran,
the State Department very much supported Iraq
in the war.
In fact, there is some evidence that the State
Department actually encouraged Detroit mayor
Coleman Young to ask Rev. Yasso to present
a key to the city of Detroit to Hussein.
In Baghdad, Saddam graciously accepted the
honor and asked Yasso, “I heard there was
a debt on your church.
How much is it?”
Yasso said yes there was, approximately for
$170,000.
Saddam gave him a check for $200,000 dollars,
enough to pay the debt and build a new recreation
hall.
In the 2003 interview, Yasso went on to say
that Saddam was an American puppet and once
the US government didn’t need him anymore,
he was no good.
However, he did admit that while Saddam Hussein
may have been
a “good person” at some point, “money
and power changed the person.”